l'annonce a été faite par le Premier
ministre polonais nous ne transférons
plus aucun armement à l'Ukraine car nous
nous armons nous-mêmes avec les armes
les plus modernes un coup dur pour
l'Ukraine en pleine contre-offensive
alors que la Pologne est l'un de ses
principaux alliés militaires 3 milliards
d'euros d'armes et d'équipements ont été
fournis par Varsovie à l'armée
ukrainienne depuis le début de la guerre
parmi lesquels chars et avion de chasse
la déclaration du gouvernement polonais
actu une série de frictions entre les
deux pays frontaliers les semaines
dernière la Pologne suivie de la Hongrie
et de la Slovaquie a choisi de maintenir
un embargo sur la vente de céréales
ukrainienne contrôlaient vie de l'Union
européenne Varsovie dit protéger les
intérêts de ses agriculteurs contre une
concurrence poussant les prix à la
baisse une priorité pour le gouvernement
de droite populiste à un mois d'élection
parlementaire
lundi l'Ukraine n'a porté plainte auprès
de l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
contre ces trois pays
en réaction le Premier ministre polonais
menace d'élargir la liste des produits
Ukrainiens interdit d'importation à la
tribune de l'ONU ce mercredi le
président Zelinski s'adresse
indirectement à son voisin
c'était larmant de voir comment certains
en Europe certains de nos amis européens
Fame la solidarité
avec ce théâtre politique autour des
céréales ils aident Moscou
des propos dénoncés par la Pologne qui a
convoqué d'urgence l'ambassadeur
ukrainien à Varsovie